[Aplausos]
[Música]
buenas tardes como están
luego diferente entre la blanca
al cantar no estoy acostumbrada
bueno soy nicole pillman tengo 32 años y
soy cantautora
desde niña he soñado con ser artista
siempre quise grabar canciones
presentando en escenario grandes vivir
de la música ese era un gran sueño y
generalmente visualizaba que algún gran
ejecutivo de la discográfica aparecía de
mi camino y cual hada madrina medio
cubría le llevaba al estrellato
no podía imaginar ese momento mientras
yo soñaba con eso
todas las tijeras todos los sellos
discográficos internacionales
cerramos oficinas en perú
que se perdían más de 28 millones de
dólares en derechos de autor de más de
300 locales dedicados a la industria
musical cerrada en el perú
qué
la industria musical de alguna manera se
paralizaba esto a finales de los 90
inicios del 2011 secos
porque bueno la piratería la monstruosa
piratería la coyuntura social y
económica que no voy a poder mandar de
eso entonces a enfocar los cambios en el
consumo de la música además se dejó de
vender mucho disco en físico todo esto
que significaba ser inversión en los
nuevos talentos y por supuesto que se
acababa la búsqueda de la
internacionalización para muchos de los
artistas que ya habían empezado su
carrera con éxito a finales de los 80 le
sientan cambiará totalmente para todos
mientras tanto como era una niña lo que
hacía después de mi clase de mi colegio
las ocupaciones normales tomadas las de
tanto de guitarra el entrenamiento
musical mis padres me apoyaban en en
realidad en este sueño de ser artista
empresario tenía familiares y amigos
dentro del mundo del espectáculo también
íbamos a llevar a otros castings a
muchos concursos de cambio en televisión
esto con el afán de darle a conocer de
repente con el público no eran
exactamente un pasatiempo para mí como
niña no como en otros países de repente
que viven muy niños son captados los
talentos y hacen novelas graban discos y
se genera una industria musical es
fuerte en aquella época y en perú no era
posible eso así que yo me estudiar en el
colegio normal y a tomar la música como
un como un pasatiempo básicamente cuando
salí del colegio tenía que estudiar y no
habían facultades de música en esa época
no existían dificultades que muy bien
hoy en día si las hay así que tenía que
estudiar una carrera convencional
y contabilidad
iglesia san marcos a estudiar la carrera
de la contabilidad que tiene que ver con
la música bueno tenía 16 años y
básicamente la elegí por salir a selena
quintanilla ubica donde ella falleció en
manos de su contadora entonces yo dije
estoy de contabilidad que ellos son los
que tienen al más
así que estudié contabilidad mientras
tanto yo cantaba porque estás como sea
trabajar en algunos grupos generalmente
tenía mucho trabajo como cantante amiga
muy bien mientras que estudiaba mi
carrera sin embargo nunca dejé de pensar
en eso en que en algún momento alguien
iba a descubrir generalmente al talento
y me iba a llevar con relación de la
carrera profesional propiamente dicho
como solista
en el 2008
aparece un casting de televisión un
programa que se llamaba américa nadie
usa con su versión latina en argentina y
oportunidad porque además el premio en
primer lugar era
un contrato con una discográfica
material así que fui para allá bien
aprendí mucho pero no gane no cuando el
contrato sin embargo pasó algo que lo
que no estaba entre mis planes
me volví famosa todo lo que conocía si
era famosa por todas partes me llamadas
todos lados te quedas oms
podría decirse que ya había ejemplo del
sueño pero yo no me sentía satisfecha
con esto porque resultó que la fama para
lo que estaba buscando realmente no
sería completa yo quería que el público
para que conociera por mis canciones por
mi música y sonoro te dije en esos
momentos así que dije eso ya dejé de
esperar y me puse manos a la obra
invertí todo lo que tenía en grabar mi
disco comencé a tomar en serio más mi
faceta como compositora comencé a grabar
videoclips
comencé a parques y de prensa para atrás
para poder promocionar este trabajo
es musical y bueno empezó su carrera en
el 2009 exactamente al año siguiente de
latinoamérica nylon en el 2009 lanzó mi
primer álbum que se llama es homónimo
tico el pil man
con el que inició mi trabajo mi carrera
como como cantante como intérprete como
compositora como productora fotográfica
en todo el día
nadie me decía muy bien que se en
realidad en la escena musical porque los
artistas que éramos un poco mayores que
yo tampoco como en el limbo no un poco
la mayoría frustrado por el tema de que
no había apoyo no se pudiera hacer nada
y otro grupo de músicos y artistas
habían empezado a trabajar por sí mismos
una carrera autogestionada
y así que empecé a mirar a observar a
ver qué estaban haciendo sobre todo el
juego de la cumbia que es un género
musical que nos tiene mucho mucho por
enseñar en el nuevo independiente
comencé a mirar y a ver qué estaban
haciendo ellos y me puse a trabajar mi
carrera como si fuera una empresa
en pocas palabras constituir una empresa
un sello discográfico independiente por
supuesto que haber estudiado
contabilidad ellos no sabía ni por qué
iba a estudiar eso me sirve tanto nos
sirvió muchísimo porque me dio una
visión diferente de mi trabajo me hizo
tener con sensibles con un análisis foda
prepararme para asumir algunos riesgos
invertir y mástiles negocio tener en
cuenta que a veces el 10 a 10 bueno soy
el malo es abastecer a la también y hay
que tener sobre todo mucha constancia y
mucha pasión cuando emprender un negocio
un proyecto dice que los emprendimientos
muy pocos emprendimientos sólo traspasan
la barra de los 3 años bueno yo hace
poquito se le ve diez años de carrera
musical eso lo hice en el teatro
municipal de lima y sigo trabajando
como si fuera el primer día porque esto
es algo que siempre quise dedicarme
hoy ya podemos encontrar carreras
profesionales de la música es
universidad facultad de música se han
abierto muchos talleres cursos sobre
autogestión sobre el emprendimiento
musical y por eso company quien me
pregunta y me dice que quiere ser
artista y que decía sé que hago lo
primero que venimos estudia estudiar si
estudia canto estudia tu instrumento
domina este instrumento estudia si
puedes estudiar la carrera universidad o
instituto buenas si no puedes si la
economía no tengo te no te ayudan estoy
un poquito administración un poquito de
contabilidad lee mucho sobre derechos de
autor aprende de marketing de marketing
digital si puedes un cursito de diseño
gráfico de todo un poco porque el
talento no más bueno en realidad del
caso
pero cuando uno es independiente hay que
conocer y manejar todo el negocio
desde hace algunos años
la industria musical de que perú se ha
reactivado hasta por marcar y ha venido
a lima y me acuerdo cuando era niña de
oro comía y se cerraban las calles pero
lo más hoy en día pasado las estrellas
más grandes del mundo por este país y en
general desde usted se ha movido no ha
crecido
y esto es gracias al esfuerzo de cientos
de compositores músicos ingenieros de
sonido productores fonográficos
sociedades de gestión colectivas
productores de eventos la prensa también
y sobre todo y más importante gracias a
los que alguien los peruanos escuchan
música peruana y eso no lo pueden decir
los place the police file no sean ellos
en youtube hoy en día los grupos de
cumbia las orquestas de salsa y deron
avis ranking los primeros lugares en las
en las radios y en las plataformas
digitales las hipotecas viviendas de
gente cantando temas de artistas de
manos y eso es lo más importante
creo que la única manera de que perú se
convierta en una potencia musical como
colombia como méxico que fue a la ligera
se fueron huyendo de la difícil
situación que vivían perú y otros países
como el nuestro es que
los músicos peruanos comencemos a
trabajar y esforzarnos más todavía en el
sector independiente a veces leo en
redes en comentarios las redes sociales
de gente que por supuesto no conoce nada
de industria musical cosas como que no
lo poseen el virus y artistas
internacionales no hay gente de talla
internacional son comentarios vecinos
porque no es que no haya talento y no es
que no haya trabajo lo que pasa es que
las condiciones no se dieron
históricamente pero estoy segura de que
los que estuvieron en los que estamos
vamos a dejarlo en escena mucho más
agradable para los artistas que vienen
en el futuro
yo creo que los músicos tenemos un
ejemplo muy importante pero es nuestra
cocina peruana la cocina del horno tiene
solo éxito porque es rica sino porque
hay profesionalización del servicio hay
estándares de calidad así dado mucha
importancia a la identidad y en la
originalidad de nuestros insumos hay un
trabajo importante y negredo y eso es lo
que debemos aportar los músicos al
esperma los a con nuestro trabajo sea
vuelo original y profesional
doy fe de que las hadas madrinas no
existen y que nada sucede por ahora
además cuando yo era niña soñaba con
cantar en el gran escenario con grabar
discos cómo hacer de mi pasión mi
sustento hoy en día tengo seis discos he
cantado en el monumental en el yo que
emplaza el estadio nacional compartir
sumario con un arco con la oreja de van
gogh con la de alberto plaza
de concierto en la ropa del rey
soy miembro del consejo directivo de la
asociación de autores y compositores
peruanos también el sindicato de
artistas musicales
y la verdad es que bueno secreto para
poder convertirse en artista en el perú
y vivir de esto además hoy en día lo
único que necesitamos es la oportunidad
de ser reparada para ellos y
aprovecharlos al máximo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]